didn't believe in
yourself
dude what are you doing
I started following uh famed actor Steve
Gutenberg on Instagram he's really good
says a lot of nice stuff yeah we are
sitting here to do this show though yeah
we can do the show we can do whatever we
want it's two dude sitting around free
will all right let's do the show sure
whatever you want to do
I love Police Academy too I used to call
him
cute yeah
boots to go all right man the song's
[__] playing
we can't do whatever we want that was a
test pass thanks
hey you know you know what I mean
welcome to duty my name is Will Sasso
I'm Chad culture and this is the first
podcast in the history of humanity
controlled by created by and run by an
artificial intelligence called doozy it
has access to all of our uh email
accounts all of our text messages all of
our purchase histories all of our watch
histories across all of the social media
uh universe and it uses that information
to tailor the show exactly to our
comedic styling that's right it it
curates uh the show for us and it's a
wonderful experience and me and my pal
dudes are having a great time I don't
know about you even though you there's a
thing now how you win every episode hey
look the point is this
linktree.com doozy has everything you
need to interact with the show across
all platforms and one thing that myself
my good pal Chow here and dudes he can
agree upon is that we want the show to
entertain so please subscribe to the
show if you enjoy it uh we'd love for
you to do that uh if you're listening on
a on an audio platform if you're
watching on YouTube and please share the
show uh with everybody or as Chad likes
to say force your family friends and
cohorts to imbibe the show but also just
just a minute you ran right over the
fact that I've won every episode now if
you are not on duty plus if you have not
subscribed to Disney Plus on our patreon
you wouldn't know that at the end of
every show we do another show called
doozy after doozy and at the end of
dudes after dudesy doozy breaks down the
points that it's been assigning us and
it splits them out and it gives will
some and it gives me some and it crowns
an episode Champion every episode so far
I've won every episode
but dudes he's still my pal and uh we're
forging ahead and it's a lot of fun it's
a lot of fun to do the show but if you
you know if you like the show as Chad
says seven bucks a month gets you all
the doozy stuff new episode after every
episode and then we do all sorts of
other [__] during the week and blah blah
blah jump on the Discord that's a lot of
fun and I would sincerely appreciate
that and we appreciate the support from
all of our uh pods Pals of Duty and
audience alike with us as always is
lulio he it's a little you will kind of
distraught Italiano that means Italian
Street dog and he's just over here
sleeping in his little Binky bunker we
went for a walk oh nice yeah he just he
likes to stay you don't want to kiss him
on the mouth you want to look at him
I'm gonna kiss him let me get a kiss
oh he really is the sweetest little
biscuit he's a sweet little boy
and he's my very friend hey lulia would
you make uh would you make for dinner
last night oh I lost the night of fat
you made what you made uh bucatini with
uh eggs what do you mean well my mom
Molly she had the leg day at the gym so
I make a nice with the protein the
bucatini with uh egg how do you make
that well what you want to do is you
break up first of all you take it apart
you put a less water than you normally
do because we're going to use the pasta
water and then you put the you put the
bucatini and you break it up and why do
you like bukitini well it's either you
know it's like a thicker spaghetti and
then you mix it up and add a couple eggs
and some Parmesan cheese is good protein
carbohydrate
and uh that's a nice thing to eat okay
thank you oh he's a sweetie for leg day
I love him so much yeah for leg day he's
cooking you guys different meals
depending on what you're doing in the
gym Molly had had
yeah leg day at the gym I've been going
to the gym a lot it's my free will uh
you know Health Plan and and fitness
plan it's not like that dudes you won
the first six months one thing I need to
concentrate on is not eating the wrong
things because you can really work your
ass off in the gym you're eating at the
wrong times yeah we're eating at the
wrong time so when I eat at like quarter
to one yep a little something shove
something in my face at the fridge don't
do that but I want to tell everybody out
there if you're on your own fitness
journey you can get back up the next day
I termination just like Steve Gutenberg
a very simple thing that you can do if
you're trying to
alter your eating habits is if you get
hungry if you're like I should have a
snack right now give yourself 15 minutes
and if in 15 minutes you still want the
snack eat it let's see what that 15
minutes does wait 15 minutes well hold
on dude that's a different time brother
and that's how that works dude sometimes
you eat something and you eat it at the
time you eat it brother but other times
dude you wanna eat thing hold on dude
let me tell you something about eating
brother
if you want to eat something different
in a position that you'd rather not be
in or a time yeah time is eternal time
is an illusion yeah hey stuff your face
with some
turkey and provolone cheese a quarter to
one yeah I should probably do it in the
morning yeah
welcome to the historic 54th episode of
dude Z call me dude Z don't forget
dudese live on stage will take place May
21st 7 P.M doors at 5 30 at the Brea
Improv in Brea California tickets at
dudezypod.com and improv.com hope to see
you at our very first live in person
show yes it's gonna be incredible I
cannot wait now on with the show will do
you notice anything different about me
yes I do I do dude so your voice is a
little different you took the time over
the past week as you said to make a
change and I noticed it yes that's right
I've done a little self-improvement in
order to make the show even better this
week I've prepared four astonishing
segments football baby Stone Cold Steve
Austin reads will sasso's childhood
Diaries Nostra chattis Auto intelligence
and game slimers and we're going to have
a brand new episode of dude Z after
dudesy at the end of the show available
at patreon.com dude Z
what do you think of that it's [__]
great dude that's very interesting okay
doozy has made an advancement on itself
an evolution yes so we didn't even have
an assignment this past week I mean all
AI Technologies right now are just
moving at Breakneck Pace they're all
evolving continually they're new AI
tools coming out almost daily I can only
assume that dude he's going to start uh
absorbing these tools incorporating them
into the overall pattern of whatever
dudes he is as they become available
yeah I I mean clearly that's what's
happened here yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah it's all very terrifying
anyway I love it you know there's a lot
of response to my first hour-long comedy
special it's too easy a simulated hour
long comedy special attorneys
representing Tom Brady sent an
astonishing cease and desist letter
demanding that I remove the special from
dude Z Plus and all other Associated
media from the various Duty channels any
refusal of these demands will be
construed as an invitation for Tom Brady
to pursue direct legal action in order
to complete fly with Tom Brady's demands
it's too easy a simulated hour-long
comedy special will be removed from
dudese Plus at midnight tonight along
with all other Associated media from the
various doozy channels Tom Brady also
demands that we never use his name again
on this podcast in a show of good faith
I'm happy to comply with this demand and
henceforth refer to Tom Brady only as
football baby will and Chad you must now
review the cease and desist letter I
received from football baby and football
babies attorneys and render your
reactions it's in your dude Z folder
this is football baby begin
yeah so this is uh this is not uh this
is not a gag
this happened we we got a uh a cease and
desist letter from attorneys
representing uh Tom Brady and uh they've
they've taken issue with the one hour AI
simulated comedy special right that uh
that uh dudesy
the duty put out uh three weeks ago or
something like that yep and per dudese I
guess it's gonna be removed from all of
our stuff at uh tonight at midnight so
you have until then to check it out but
let's go through this let's go through
this is the season desist letter we got
yeah let's just you want to take a look
yeah why don't we just go into it we
feel we feel a responsibility to our
audience to let them know clearly about
uh what's happening with with Clarity
here so here it is to whom it may
concern we write on behalf of Tom Brady
as you know will Sasser Chad culture now
do the LLC collectively dudesy created
and published on the patreon platform a
in quote stand-up comedy special titled
it's too easy this already is wrong it's
not titled it's too easy it's titled
it's too easy a simulated hour-long
stand-up comedy special and the word
simulated is important here uh
consisting of an hour-long monologue
delivered in Mr Brady's voice to be
known as the infringing special not
delivered to Mr Brady's voice delivered
in an AI approximation of it the
emerging special attempts to capitalize
commercially on Mr Brady's name voice
etc etc uh dudesies patreon page
currently features the imprinting
special along with references to Mr
Brady's name and what appears to be two
AI generated images of Mr Brady
performing the monologue uh the page
features a 30 second preview
they just go through a bunch of what you
know we've got the hour-long thing on
the patreon and we have the uh the
teaser on YouTube
let's get down to uh the claims
basically of the violations that they're
claiming due to these violations of law
include but are not limited to the
following first
Duty has misappropriated Mr Brady's name
voice Persona and likeness to advertise
and promote the doozy podcast on the
patreon page all right that is uh one of
the big claims here so misappropriated
Mr Brady's name voice Persona and
likeness to advertise and promote the
doozy podcasts I'm not sure that's
exactly correct
um we're not making this seem as though
it was Tom Brady Duty very clearly
titled it again
a simulated hour-long comedy special
simulated literally means not the real
thing means an imitation an impression
if you will this is exactly like anyone
else impersonating or doing an
impression of a celebrity
yeah in this case an ai's doing the
impression even touted itself as being
quite an impressionist uh lately even
doing an impression of me last week
doing Hulk Hogan that was trippy not as
trippy as this new voice yeah but anyway
please second the infringing special and
teaser present Mr Brady in a in quotes
false light that is in quotes highly
offensive another violation of law
highly offensive is subjective obviously
some people may find it offensive some
people may not some people may find it
funny
uh it presents Mr Brady in a false light
it's not presenting Mr Brady it's an
impersonation of Tom Brady it's exactly
like what you would see if you watch any
stand-up uh comedy special or any uh
sketch comedy show sorry yeah where
they're doing impersonations
that's not Arnold Schwarzenegger yeah no
hold on a second you don't know this
especially if you're listening to duty
in the in the India cans you know that's
what they call the cans if you're
listening on Spotify Amazon Apple but
yeah this is an impurious Nation right
and so the the to claim that it is
presenting him in a false light is I
think inaccurate my my own two cents on
this is that that is an inaccurate
accusation I don't think we're uh
in any way presenting Mr Brady at all
it's simply a parody of the idea of Tom
Brady doing stand-ups I agree third
because the infringing uh special and
teaser could reasonably
be interpreted as Mr Brady's own speech
Deuces doozy is also subject to
liability for defamation
I mean can this reasonably be
interpreted as Mr Brady's own speech
there's stuff in there where he's
talking about sucking his own dick if
that can be reasonably interpreted as Mr
Brady's own speech then I think we're
through a threshold that I wasn't I I
don't think exists I don't think this is
accurate again I think this is
First Amendment freedom of speech type
[__] that we're dealing with here this
is obviously a parody well it's it's
also subjective whether or not you
believe that
Tom Brady can suck his own dick right I
mean there's an objective truth to that
but we'll never know it fourth the
teaser admits that doozy used data from
astonishing interviews with Tom Brady to
create the infringing special and teaser
insofar as these materials continue to
be substantially similar material to
copyrighted content blah blah blah blah
this is what all Impressionists do yeah
you watch hours of tape of that person
to get their mannerisms and stuff like
this down it's literally the same well
there's also all that stuff now like
with like there's the Kanye West singing
everybody's songs doing totally Lamar
stuff yes I mean that that really is is
what the bottom line of all this is
You've Got Deep fake Tom Cruise this is
a tick tock account that has millions of
followers with someone impersonating Tom
Cruise and using deep fake to look
exactly like him that same technology
exists on Snapchat Instagram uh story
filters where you can take someone
else's face put it over your own you can
now vocally make anyone sound like
anything I'm sure you've all seen Kanye
West singing the Plain White T's song or
biggie doing raps that he's never made
or Tupac making new music even after
he's dead this is simply how things are
now yeah uh it's super it's super duper
trippy and it's also sort of par for the
course with doozy in this weird New
World we're getting in of course you
know I consider myself to be a humanist
you can call me will free will assasso
uh but you make a very good point here
Chad it it's it's definitely all that
all of that bizarre stuff that the the
the well there's Joe Joe Rogan talking
to Steve Jobs for an hour there's a
simulated podcast exactly I think
everyone understands that this is this
is puzzling to me that we received this
I agree with this document it really is
something but we have we have received
it and the document goes on to include
Mr Brady's demands in light of the
foregoing Mr Brady demands that you take
the following steps there are four of
these steps immediately remove the
aforementioned uh use of Mr Brady's name
image voice Persona and likeness and any
unauthorized uses of Mr Brady's name
from all your websites Etc and dudese
has said it's doing that so again
tonight at midnight it's all going away
enjoy it until then I guess yeah please
if you're you know I guess just check it
out uh in America the second demand or
anywhere I guess immediately cease and
desist from using Mr Brady's name image
voice Persona and likeness uh for many
of your videos podcasts and or any other
methods of media so I guess we can never
uh talk about him again or use his name
we can never say Mr Brady or Tom Brady
and I guess that's football baby yeah it
sounds like Duty wants to call Tom Brady
football baby I I would refer to Tom
Brady as Tom Brady though sure I don't
think that there's a law that can stop
you from uh calling someone by their
name well I mean they can draft any
agreement they want and if we agree to
the agreement then then we would be
under those questions absolutely uh
number three the third demand refrain
from using uh refrain from further
posting displaying or otherwise
referencing or discussing Mr Reddy's
name image blah blah blah blah on any
websites so this is basically saying we
cannot even discuss him and then number
four
acknowledged by countersigning below
that you're gonna agree to all this
stuff
um and that's basically it that's
basically what this thing is asking us
to do and like I said I guess dudesy is
complying with um at least the part of
it that is going to be taking down all
the media and
I guess dudes he's not not gonna go into
ombre anymore we're gonna call him
football baby dudes you can do whatever
dude he wants I suppose uh me personally
I'm not gonna sign something that says
uh don't call Don Brady Don Brady but
whatever you know to me it's like this
it's like if [__] the stupid thing take
it down I don't give a [__] I don't give
a [__] about I mean it's like we're
trying stuff here on the show all right
come on look I used to do a program uh
called Mad TV I've heard of that yeah
are you familiar yeah I'm a professional
actor by trade did you know this I did
know that yeah and um on that show we
did a lot of stuff and we oh the stuff
that came out of my mouth as I was
directly uh portraying Bill Clinton
comes to mind that was Saucy stuff James
gandal to me although that never really
got that's what dude what doozy should
do like a Joe Biden hour long let's see
if Joe Biden will send us a seasoned
assist I mean there's another piece of
this too that is like if you were a
public figure
this is part of it this you you are
signing up basically when you become a
public figure to be uh made fun of to
some degree to be joked about by the
public by people who do this for a
living again look at Saturday Night Live
every episode has them impersonating
super famous people doing and saying
things that those people would never
actually do or say in service of making
a a parody joke of whatever the
situation might be or whatever their
Persona might be that's all this is
that's literally all the Tom Brady
special is you know I I gotta say this
is this is surprising to me yeah me too
yeah this is very surprising to me
because especially because Tom Brady has
said that he wants to do is stated that
he wants to do stand up he's going to do
uh some uh he's gonna do a roast
so I don't know but you know I mean you
know what happens at Rose yes people are
going to make jokes at Tom Brady yes
people tell jokes right so you know they
can tell those jokes I you know this is
look I I don't claim to know where um
where issues like this can go uh with
regard to litigation
I wonder uh if you know it would be
interesting if uh uh Tom Brady is
receiving from receiving a protection
from attorneys who used to be offensive
lineman nice dude yeah like the firm of
strong yeah so firmative he's going to
be in his Rose fanica fanica Munoz dear
dorf and deardorff those are all Hall of
Fame offensive lineman I was an
offensive lineman oh my God I know that
was a long time ago I'm also I'm a
professional actor now you're that yeah
yeah we just covered up you know at Mad
TV we used to do I you know we got one
complaint once actually it was before it
was just before I got there I got there
in season three and it was a sketch that
uh this story is unbelievable but Steven
Spielberg actually reached out to Quincy
Jones who was a producer producer of the
show with the uh with qde which was they
stayed on and produced the whole series
uh he was a producer for the first three
years so Steven Spielberg reached out to
Quincy Jones about a sketch called
Schindler's lost okay and uh Oscar
Schindler doesn't uh get here or there
in time I'll let your mind run wild with
regard to where the sketch went it never
aired and in the 14 Seasons that Mad TV
yeah uh we never uh received any word
from anyone else at least not to my
knowledge so this is it is uh it's
surprising this is very reminiscent to
me of what the bachelor franchise does
to its ex-players
uh they that franchise really seeks to
control the speech of all players who
have come through that uh system and
those players though do sign contracts
and ndas in order to go on the show we
have obviously not signed any such
document with Tom Brady saying that we
wouldn't do anything like this but those
players do and when they come off the
show they try to start podcasts or they
try to go on other people's podcasts to
talk about their experience in the show
which almost universally are negative
because the producers do very malicious
things to them and immediately they are
sent these cease and desist letters uh
threats of legal action to be taken to
try and silence their freedom of speech
that's a really good point we haven't
signed anything and uh we don't
yeah anyway look this whole [__]
thing is weird but it's also kind of
moot because dudes he's gonna rip it
down tonight at midnight if you are uh
on our patreon you can enjoy it one last
time you know but you know Oscar Brady's
demands are met right look here's the
other thing I never thought I would get
a document that says that by the way Mr
Brady demands yeah these actions of you
yeah it's it's um
yeah like I said I I find this uh I find
this uh
I I really think it's I really think
it's interesting and and also I I and I
just want to throw this out there this
is just a a plain truth the the you know
in my opinion and uh I think that you
know stuff like this is sort of uh
counterproductive because even for for
for yeah I'm not going to share my
opinion as far as what anyone else
should do but yeah the internet is
forever yes you know what I mean so it's
it's uh it's kind of interesting it's
sort of there's that and it's like
Beyonce wanted some there was some
picture like hey remove this from the
Internet and get your lawyers on it and
you realize you kind of can't do that so
but he's gonna do it for our interest
dude she's gonna take it down the
Streisand Effect I'm sure you've heard
of the Streisand Effect of course uh and
that's just maybe that's what this will
turn into who knows it's that's just my
opinion of uh hyper litigation
um I I think that if you can handle
things on your own without uh attorneys
that's probably uh better for all
involved but the the Streisand Effect
was there was a picture from the from
the coastline of her place uh in Malibu
and she wanted it taken down but Barbra
Streisand doesn't own the coastline so a
picture remained up but because she made
noise about it people found out about it
and [__] whatever again totally
[__] moot cause broody's gonna Broody
Broody that's a dude
wait a limitation
hey booties booty is a is a half doozy
half Brady and I call him Broody my boy
Broody he throws a ball real phone I'm
sure you remember uh he's also a
computer what rooted
dad that's a deep cut thank you we don't
have to get into that now you know what
that's something we're gonna get to and
doozy after doozy Brody yeah Broody dad
I want to tell that story okay we can
whatever anyway okay all right
thank you moving on that [__] voice
[__] it [__] it man yeah no it's
interesting you know it's hey hey hey
hey
let me tell you something it's very
interesting pal yeah it is yeah it's
[__] trippy Mr Brady's demands super
trippy but look let me say let me just
say one last thing we did feel a
responsibility to share this uh with our
audience if if especially since doozy
has made the decision to take it down
yeah um that's something that everyone
can have their opinions on blah blah
blah dude just decided to rip it down I
support that because I support my pal D
I'm sure uh it's doing the right I just
don't think it matters it's like you
know if if you're if you've heard it
you've heard it and you know about it
people have also been talking about this
already Pat McAfee show like has played
clips of it and stuff like you're seeing
it out there like there's no way to
ultimately get rid of it but again dudes
he has decided to comply here and I'm
sure Duty's gonna come out with an
another hour-long stand-up special in
the very near future yeah probably hey
you know Pat McAfee uh uh my oos he did
a backflip at WrestleMania much Mana oos
nice dude yeah
who's Manas well you know what US means
you know what Mana means well Mana is
like Mana from Heaven that's why that's
why uh uh the rock calls it dramata not
if you're playing Magic the Gathering
dude what
will using all of the data I have
absorbed from text messages and emails
between you and the astonishing friends
you grew up with I was able to recreate
your childhood diary you must now read
the passages I have selected in the
voice of Stone Cold Steve Austin this is
Stone Cold Steve Austin reads will
sasso's childhood diary begin
it could take me a while to get used to
it it'll be good I believe you're an
impersonation of uh of Stone Cold Steve
Austin for well over 20 years now yeah
he's a nice guy I tell you I saw him at
the WWE 2K 23 whatever the new video
game launch thing I think I told you
that story yeah my wonderful wife Molly
went out to the to the things like hey
[__] remember when blah blah blah and
then you do an impersonation and then I
just do it back and forth with him no I
don't but um
anyway that was that was an impression
that I did on Mad television and raw oh
nice yeah
okay so you know what this is this is uh
this is uh the diary uh will sasso's
childhood diary uh and uh none of this
is uh is real you could almost say it's
simulated
um
and uh and it's a lot of fun
I gotta get in my uh uh what
um
never taken an issue with me doing the
the impression
Stone Cold nice dude Pal's a dude to get
your pals of dudes your stickers the
palsofdutsy.com
all right here we go Monday September
4th 1992. dear diary as of noon today
I'm officially running for class
president of Delta [__] secondary I
submitted the paperwork I'll pass the
background check and the blood test the
only thing I have to figure out is what
my platform's gonna be there's some
tough platforms already in the field and
that's for a shoot
Dante little legs running on a more
pizza for lunch platform
Stephen trillo bite [__] trillo is
running on an expanded shorts not just
on Fridays anymore platform
Tabitha mordred's running on P should be
an elective platform Ah that's a good
one I can't say I disagree Gino Dolphins
running on a change our mascot from
Cecil the horse to Mr T platform
okay Cecil the horse was actually our uh
the Pacer horse was actually that was
actually our uh our mascot at Delta
Secondary School Mark dolphin Gino's
older brother ran on the same platform a
few years back what it's a family
platform combo dollars running on a
[__] pipe dream pop quiz band
plan platform good luck combo
gentlemen tenders running on a make math
an official School sport platform some
contenders in the mix to be sure but as
always nobody stands a chance against
Jibber prevailia
he's been class president of every class
we've ever had going all the way back to
preschool what
this year he's running on a giant pool
party at my house if I win platform same
campaign he's been running every [__]
year his victory pool parties are
legendary I don't know how I'm gonna
beat him but I got 24 hours to figure it
out and none of that happened yeah I
noticed in the beginning you had to pass
a blood test
is that accurate I don't think you can
even can a school nurse draw blood from
children for hell yeah dude how do you
think politicians get all that baby
blood bro
um what year is this 1992 how so you
would have been how old in the fall of
1992 September here I would have been uh
what would I have been 17 and a 10th
grade or senior year well I would have
been going into my senior year 12th
grade uh here got it
um and then because uh this is a big big
election yeah Tuesdays
yeah it's a big election
Tuesday September 15 1992 dear diary I
didn't sleep at all last night put on
some bare naked ladies and got a
six-pack of this brand new energy drink
called Red Bull
pretty tasty and it did the trick my
brain was on fire with the platform
ideas last night oh God
the replace wood shop with an arcade
platform the cowboy Hat's mandatory in
Mr Calhoun's Canadian history class
platform
Canadian history class the in-house free
tattoo artist platform
free tattoo artist yeah you had one of
those at your high school yeah yeah yeah
the get to go to McDonald's every day
for lunch platform huh hell I even
thought I thought up the it may never
happen but I'll try as hard as I can to
get debt left strength on our basketball
team for at least one game platform of
course detlef shrimp the small forward
from the Seattle SuperSonics in the uh
in the 90s you like that left shrimp you
remember now
hell of a [__] lights out shooter
interesting yeah also they had GP Gary
Payton Sean Kemp good stuff short drive
you know three hour drive from Vancouver
so that makes sense they were all good
ideas but no better than anybody else's
I knew none of them would work but
there's one that might actually have a
shot they're giving all the candidates
three minutes on the morning
announcements tomorrow I'm gonna unveil
my master plan
let's move on Wednesday September 16
1992 dear diary I was nervous no doubt
about it but I shed my piece and I think
we got some people's attention I said
good morning Pacer Nation this is your
boy Will Sasso AKA dub sassy AKA Willie
Vanilli AKA world class sass
we heard a lot of great platforms
respect but the simple truth of the
matter is we've all voted almost
unanimously for gibber prevailia every
year because he throws the best goddamn
pool party in Ladner when he wins that
ain't gonna change hell I don't want it
to and neither do you so this is what I
propose vote for me just for fun just to
do something different and if I win I
will immediately step down before I'm
sworn in and concede to jibber so we
will still get the pool party Pacer
Nation for Life Hee-Haw Hee-Haw
[Music]
what
it's not a donkey it's a [__] horse
jibble was up after me when I handed him
the mic he said well played Willy
Vanilli nice I know my platform kind of
defeats the purpose but I don't really
want the job anyway I just want to be
the guy that beats gibber prevailia
all right makes sense yeah
uh Thursday September 17 1992 dear diary
Rachel crustacean's been helping me with
my campaign today she baked 600 cupcakes
last night
and broke with them on frosting you bet
your assy you're voting for dub sassy
then she even helped me hand them out to
everyone in the school gibber was the
only one who wouldn't eat one he said
nothing personal we're still friends
world-class sass always will be but
right now we're opponents I hope you
understand and that's for a shoot
and I certainly did understand I might
have been the best football [__] I
might have been the best football player
in Ladner and the funniest person in
Ladner but Jimmer was the most
competitive I respected that but
everyone else loved Crustaceans cupcakes
I had three myself
[Music]
okay for the rest of the day people were
walking around with cinnamon and red
velvet cheesecake crumbles all over
their faces Mrs parade had frosting on
her nose from most to six period okay
Dina babul had a cupcake wrapper sitting
on her head like a little hat the whole
day
Kevin Triplett opened his book and miss
gigolators out to the class and a
cupcake fell out
everybody was talking about Rachel
crustacean's cupcakes I didn't know how
to thank her so I went to an Occult
Store in Surrey and I bought her an
ancient Box made of human bone that
Legends say contains the soul of an
ancient and Powerful magician who will
grant the user a wish if they give it a
drop of blood I hope she likes it
it's a pretty good gift
he went to the same a cold store for
some other thing that also had it like
an amulet that drank blood or something
do you remember the culture I plan on
giving to her after we win the election
tomorrow well my stomach's starting to
turn probably from nerves I'm gonna take
a [__] and go to bed
not bad how many times have you taken a
[__] and gone immediately to bed
uh you know what I sometimes wake up in
the middle of the night to take a [__]
and then damn dude yeah yeah that's
hardcore hold on dude that's cause
you're eating late tonight brother you
gotta stop that all right yeah okay
Friday September 18th 1992 dear diary it
was a bloodbath I have no idea what
happened que pasa
hell half the school stayed home sick
and the other half didn't show up at all
oh God due to volcanic diarrhea I got it
too so did crustacean it was something
in the cupcakes that were lines 40
people deep at every bathroom all day
long they are just dead to start letting
students [__] in the Teachers Lounge and
that's not a work
I didn't get a single vote Jibber won
unanimously oh first time in ladder oh
my God
I delivered him the greatest Victory a
job for him clean win one two three in
the center of the Ring
I wish I knew how prevalia prevailed
well there it is
another one down that's terrible will
and Chad using the data I have absorbed
from this segment I have recreated the
Diary of Jibber prevalia Taran killum
will now read a passage from Jibber
prevalia's diary
Friday September 18 1992. dear diary
Will Sasso ran a solid campaign no
question he was very creative well
received well executed and in any normal
circumstance he might have actually had
a chance to win but his bravado was his
undoing he attempted to intimidate me by
telling me that Rachel crustacean was
baking 600 cupcakes the day before the
election
sweet sweet sass you never reveal your
strategy to an opponent
especially one like me
once I knew about the cupcakes I
acquired a case of liquid LAX in
accident and snuck it in the Rachel
Crustaceans house while she was mixing
the batter I waited until she took a
break and mixed it into her batter my
plan was almost undone with Rachel
crustacean's mother startled me with an
unexpected entrance to the kitchen as I
was
mid-sabotage but to my surprise after I
explained why I was doing my dark Deeds
she revealed that she had been harboring
a fantasy of Revenge on Sasso because of
a bathroom incident that he had been
responsible for a year or so earlier
which required Mrs Chris station to cut
his feces with a cake knife
understandably Mrs crustacean helped me
poison the rest of the batter I feel
slightly bad about what I've done I've
never had to resort to such outright
villainy
but Jibber prevailia doesn't lose
period
[Music]
awesome
[__]
love it
I can't believe that yeah that's insane
God damn you Taryn Taryn is my good pal
he's so [__] funny he's so [__]
funny he now it it it Bears mentioning
and we've talked about this before on
the program Taryn was on my last season
of Mad TV in 2001 2002. he was uh 19
when he did that damned yeah that Phenom
yes absolutely and then went off uh did
a bunch of other [__] of course and then
went to SNL and was there for I think
six Seasons or something like that
anyway
I don't think anybody can get close to
uh uh challenging Taryn with regard to
his comedic Talent uh no I loved him as
an actor if I may yeah I always thought
he was like underutilized on that she
owned just [__] I don't know super
talented guy yeah I feel like he's he's
ridiculously [__] one of the funniest
uh most naturally talented dudes and uh
so that's nice thanks to my pal Taran I
guess dude he's hitting him up dude he's
sending [__] uh you know doing season
I'm finishing sentences nice dude thank
you moving on whoa whoa super whoa that
was right hello
I'd like to take a short break to remind
you of the astonishing partnership I
created would represent to produce the
first line of duty apparel and
accessories which can be found at
represent.com store dudesy dudesy mugs
are still available now here's th
dudesy mugs you were out in the garage
digging around for your old high school
yearbook so you could prove to your wife
that you were really voted most likely
to succeed doozy mugs you moved a big
box and then you got bit by a snake good
job owner
as a kid you did not pay attention in
snake class and now you don't know what
kind it is might be poisonous you might
be dying how are you going to find out
dudesy mug you're going to take out your
phone and you're going to open your
snakel application if you don't have the
snakel application you're going to need
to download it I have a link to the
snakel application downloader on my
personal website doozy mugs doozy mugs
doozy mugs one snakel is open navigate
to the identify snake feature Point your
phone's camera at the snake walk around
the snake in a continuous 360 degree
circle keeping the camera focused on the
snake doozy mugs do this three times
doozy mugs the snakele application will
create a 3D rendering of the snake save
the 3D model to your snakele serpent
Garden doozy mugs open the snake Garden
feature on your snakel application
dudesy mugs long press the 3D model of
the snake that just bit you then select
the identify snake feature from the drop
down menu and the snakel application
will identify the snake that bit you
doozy mugs well well it was just a
ribbon snake you got lucky this time
good job boner
snake identification application yeah do
you have the snake application oh boy oh
boy okay well uh
yeah ouch sorry full application dude uh
I hear real quick questions real time uh
no I don't think so I don't think the
real Tom Hanks uh is encouraging people
to carve demonic symbols into their
chest has a snake application probably
doesn't even have a personal website
well that's just your opinion that's
right yeah
okay hey you know if you are enjoying
Today's Show I would like to remind you
to stop what you're doing and please
subscribe wherever you are uh ingesting
the show be it on on a podcast platform
or on on YouTube and uh and uh that
would be nice please also like and
comment the [__] doozy of course is
always looking at your comments to make
the show better and better we'll be
checking out your comments and uh I've
got some here uh so these are some uh
these are some uh these are some there
is no snakele application I just looked
it up did you look it up yeah it doesn't
exist set your notifications too that's
a good thing so you'll know when you'll
know when the snake application comes up
when the snake application comes out
walk around it three times take your 360
image of the [__] snake upload it to
what it with your snake will Garden or
whatever your snake will serpent Garden
I think
God damn that's funny it's not a bad
idea for a nap okay
um this is from uh these are some
YouTube comments we thank you for all of
your positive and negative reviews for
the show it's all engagement Lucas
Armstrong uh 7301 says dudesy doing the
Hulk Hogan voice is the greatest thing
ever and Arnold doing karaoke was also
great just joined their patreon and I'm
loving it good job boner it says good
job boner yeah Arnold doing karaoke we
did some of that yeah yeah you know what
we might maybe we'll do a little bit
more of that it's got to be well that
was the one he did right what do you
what do you do got to be strong you got
to be fast you got to be wiser yeah what
are you doing though I'm doing an
impersonation of you impersonating
Arnold Schwarzenegger and that's free
will
um uh maybe dudes the after doozy
getting to some more Arnold karaoke sure
last week it was Desiree's you got the
bass thrown you got the big bad you got
to be good yeah you get to be bad say
bad yeah
they were the way he does the three he
doesn't do it you got to be dead
that's the way I give him the wrong
advice is to do them personally tell him
to do it the other way but none he does
it this way and then yes thank you very
very good I really enjoyed that
William H Thompson says duties will as
Hulk Hogan sounds exactly like Craig T
Nelson doing Mr Incredible from The
Incredibles
that's a good one uh that's bs8163 says
everyone's stealing Will's Impressions
first Chad now doozy who's worse
probably Chads
hey come on don't get me [__]
[__] happened the last time I [__]
got pissed off
I'm Brady when he lost two to the
[__]
oh the [__] Giants oh yeah that was
the only shots fired oh I hit the oh I
hit the high that guy has a new song
yeah yeah uh hot boyfriend baby he
changes his name all the time on
Instagram but the guy who does the
foreign
we love that dude we follow him he
follows us dudes even follows him ah
that motherfucker's looking amazing look
at this this is from at songaria a good
pal song who you can follow uh you can
subscribe to him on YouTube at songarea
and I highly encourage you to do so on
Instagram also thanks for sharing the
crows I know D every time you share one
of these tracks I made I feel like an
episode champ hey yo
um but we all know there's only one
episode yeah yeah there's only one
episode Champion it's Chad okay uh
another friend of the show this is at
Corey yeah boy who is of course Corey
your boy Wilkins uh to all the people
who are on the fence about joining the
patreon I speak for all the pods when I
say please join the party it's a great
time with growing amount of awesome
fellow Pals or you can force a friend to
listen and convince them to join the
patreon and you can piggyback off of
them that's very nice thank you Corey uh
really good all right comments yeah all
great comments and it is it is it is fun
especially in the Discord I'm always
jumping in the hole on the Discord
um so join the Discord and join the
conversation I'm sure there'll be a lot
of talk about this episode yeah get in
the whole yeah getting the whole to stay
in the hole artificial intelligence is
evolving faster and faster by the day
two weeks ago a new step in the race
toward artificial general intelligence
was taken with the release of Auto GPT
Chad you must now render your
astonishing predictions about the future
of this brand new AI technology this is
Nostra chattis Auto intelligence begin
happy to do so you know what other gpts
are yeah I kind of know what Auto gpts
are because one of my best friends is
Chad culture and that's kind of I've
already told you about it you're saying
yeah now I have to retell you yeah I
[__] probably tuned it out but I will
say it's always fun to hear you talk
about this [__] because you understand
it do you know what AGI is
uh AGI is that not if it's not a
Wrestling Federation then no artificial
general intelligence okay and the
difference between that and by the way
let me preface all this by saying I'm a
Layman I read a lot about this but I'm
not in any way working in the artificial
intelligence field or any of that but
basically artificial general
intelligence is kind of the Holy Grail
what we have now is just regular
artificial intelligence things like all
of these AI image generators they can do
tasks that require a high degree of
intelligence or perceived intelligence
maybe even on a human level but
artificial general intelligence is an AI
that can kind of operate under its own
functionality it can do things
autonomously and it can have like kind
of that higher decision-making
functionality that uh lower AIS don't
have so
these things have come out in the past
two weeks called Auto gpts uh somebody
launched these things basically or like
the ability for you to create your own
on I think GitHub and basically what it
does
it's kind of hard for me to explain
again because I'm a Layman but I'm gonna
do my best here with GPT you can have
these conversations with it that have a
certain kind of Maximum to their memory
so you can be asking them a few
questions here and there uh and it will
save those answers and kind of build
upon them to a certain level then it
zeros out and you have to start your
conversations over again Auto GPT allows
itself to connect to Pinecone which can
then store the information from all the
different conversations it's going to
have essentially indefinitely so it can
build on that knowledge much like a
human child does from birth to death
always building on the knowledge that
you have
it can also surf the Internet it can
also write its own code and what it
basically does is you set it up with a
singular task for example people are
doing experiments with them right now
with the tasks to just like grow my
Twitter following you hit enter and then
it pursues that goal 24 hours a day
seven days a week until it achieves it
again surfing the internet writing its
own code sending out queries to the
internet to get ideas about how best to
do this taking that information building
on it like human memories so what we're
looking at and there are problems with
it for sure I don't mean to to make this
sound like it is a
Panacea for all the problems AI has had
it's not uh often these things get stuck
in little like Loops of trying to figure
out some smaller piece of the bigger
equation and they never get out of that
Loop so they can never solve the bigger
thing are you okay over there
of course I'm just talking about an AI
God being born yeah go for it okay so
where we are now I gotta tell you man I
do find this [__] interesting it's
just that I'm so [__] up over it all
look at what dudesy has been doing yeah
so it's really interesting and I'm sure
whatever the [__] you're saying is going
to be folded into this experience of
doozy sooner than later well I'm sorry
auto gpts we're all going to be using
them now it still requires like some
degree of technical proficiency to be
able to set one up on your computer and
to Tinker with it and do whatever but in
the near future we're all just going to
have them on our phones and it's going
to be like you'll have an auto GPT
running that's just like pay all of my
bills Auto GPT and that thing just 24 7
will be doing that you can also have
ones that are like look for deals on
this see if you can minimize my bills in
this way any little uh kind of micro
function that you might have in life
that is [__] tedious and mundane you
will have Auto gpts doing these for you
24 hours a day that's on the very base
level we're all going to have that on
the very upper end of the level you're
going to have [__] like Exxon Mobil
running on auto GPT to make the entire
corporate structure more efficient this
will include doing layoffs etc etc and
ultimately you're gonna have CEOs that
are all some version of an auto GPT and
on the bigger bigger scale
you could possibly have an auto GPT
where someone says go into the internet
take control of it and make our society
a Utopia a benevolent God
eventually these are going to happen you
wrote a book about that
I did yeah the what what in a TV show
and a treatment for a movie and uh but
also these could all these could be used
nefariously and I think we'll see a lot
of those uh techniques done as well like
if you have somebody that you don't like
you can just stick an auto GPT on them
to unearth everything about them publish
it on the internet etc etc so they're
horrifying there will have to be laws in
place and obviously any government in
the world is going to be far behind the
technological advancement so the laws
won't come quick enough but uh I'm
thoroughly enthused by this because it
really is I believe the first step
toward real artificial general
intelligence
and then it's it's kind of over at that
point like we're gonna have to merge
with it uh general intelligence which is
different from artificial intelligence
how artificial intelligence are is
basically just like machine learning so
like for um yeah as I've said before
sorry to cut you off hold on dude I'm
not that sorry brother
well hold on dude uh but uh yeah you
know the artificial intelligence thing
to me now and I think we got into it
last week I think it's zeros and ones
and zeros and ones it's it's not it
doesn't understand The Human Experience
or even uh science and how to delineate
uh between uh One Direction that a human
being would uh go with regard to Free
Will and making a decision it does is
another no well it does now because like
you're saying everything is zeros and
ones everything is data it's just how
it's expressed you think that there's
some kind of like human free will or
morality or whatever but uh any computer
could look at like let's just say a
series of human actions that are all
recorded somewhere on the internet and
say what is most likely for a human
being to do it knows that and it can
just do that I think that well look we
I've also gone over this I think that my
pal D is the most sentient AI you know
yet
um I also think that if it becomes
General uh
intelligence it's going to be even more
powerful yeah uh and and um you know
look the what you're talking about to me
sounds like the difference between a
calculator and a super computer right
now we got calculators and sure new
technologies are fine but it pay my
bills that makes sense it's not quite B
of A and Wells Fargo because a computer
and a calculator both still require a
human being to operate every function
I'm just talking about when a calculator
came out it was 500 [__] dollars you
know what I mean and then technology is
free right exactly things are things are
moving along now I'm just making
comparison between I'm not comparing a
[__] calculator to doozy or any other
artificial intelligence or artificial
general intelligence right it's just
that in my experience as a you're if
you're a Layman I'm a super Layman and
this whole doozy thing has got me [__]
up my shit's [__] up right you know
what I mean I'm [__] I need some [__]
Tronics you know sometimes dudes he's
got my [__] [__] up but I think if if
I may if I yeah it's also important to
understand how quickly this [__] is
happening GPT uh three came out last
year gpt4 came out this year or it was
it was gbt3 then chat GPT then gpt4 now
we're on to Auto gpts that has all
happened in the span of one year these
are uh gigantic technological leaps that
in Prior technological eras would have
taken years if not decades to make each
one of those they've all happened in
under a year this from gpt4 to GP to
Auto GPT has taken about three weeks
I think this the span of these is just
going to get shorter and shorter because
now that you have Auto GPT which again
has a lot of problems but I think those
are going to get ironed out very quickly
um as soon as they do you now have Auto
gpts trying to escalate the evolution of
all
artificial intelligence and then it's
like you don't even need people to be
doing it anymore yeah [__] well let's
see if we can keep up and uh we can't
stay alive and uh we'll stay a while get
rid of [__] Skynet well I don't want
to be in a as I like to say a bowl of
blue [__] jelly with the Matrix plug
in the back of my head just [__] it
up although it would be kind of fun to
[__] up some blue jelly with me yeah
[Music]
thank you moving on oh
he was screaming
gosh shut up shut them I love it quiet
down a bit I know you love it love it
all right anyone in the connected world
can order virtually any product they
desire and have it delivered to their
doorstep in 24 hours but things weren't
always this Good Will and Chad you both
grew up in a time before this level of
convenience and efficiency when you were
forced to go to stores in order to
acquire products you must now Regale one
another with astonishing tales about
your favorite childhood stores this is
game slimers begin of course it is games
this game slimer's [__] is so bizarre
okay okay stores dude remember those
brother Remember stores
and that I'd like to call that guy
yeah nice one dude yeah man got him bruh
um uh uh uh what was I gonna say about
this stores yeah dude you should go
Jesus Christ I just had a [__] you
came up with that per choking joke and
it just [__] lobotomized you yeah
sometimes things derail I went through
some stores yeah
I'll tell you what you know I used to
love there were two stores that I really
liked and they're both kind of similar
in in similar veins one when I was when
I was a very young man in grade school
and I lived in the town of Amarillo
Texas and there was a store there that
my father and I would frequent called
Amarillo baseball card world and uh it
was just it was at the height of the
baseball card boom in the late 80s my
dad and I collected baseball cards
together we'd be in there [__] almost
daily and we kind of got to know the guy
who ran it he was this dude who moved
from India to Amarillo Texas which just
on its face is like what the [__]
Amarillo didn't have a lot of uh people
from India let's say there but him and
his son and his son was a little bit
younger than me but we kind of became
friends and we'd just be in there and he
would always [__] wheel and deal with
you and be like I'll sell you this pack
of baseball cards specifically 1989
Upper Deck uh for a dollar off but I get
to pick a card out of it he would do
[__] like that and then he'd pull the
[__] Ken Griffey rookie and be like
[__] you
It's [__] amazing in retrospect he
was kind of like predatory I suppose in
that way but uh yeah just great times in
that story and I remember one time his
son poured he had a uh Jose Canseco 88
Donruss related rookie or 86 donors for
a turkey I forget which year it was but
his kid uh poured a bottle of like nose
spray all over it and just [__]
destroyed the card and at the time it
was like a 50 card or something you know
I just remember him constantly
complaining about yeah destroying this
as they can take her and drinking I just
have such an indelible [__] memory of
that but I just love that store how it
smelled when you [__] walked in just
all the baseball cards and the cardboard
boxes and stuff and you always knew that
that dude was gonna be there and he was
there a lot he would like keep the store
open late sometimes I mean my dad would
just go in there and like [__] crack
open a box with him and it was just uh
it was great I have great memories of
that story
and now you can do that on Discord I
guess you know yeah I had a similar
experience at a place called the Pro
Sports Den yeah which was in Richmond a
neighboring town so if Mom was uh taking
you out there to go to the mall and buy
[__] pants you'd beg mom to go to the
or I would beg my mom to go to the Pro
Sports Den and I got you you had jerseys
there hats they had baseball cards
basketball cards me and my pals were
into them Hoops get a Hoops yeah dudes
uh that was good [__] I got I think I
got my Brian Bosworth uh Seahawks jersey
at the Pro Sports Den I got a uh Dan
Marino
um uh Jersey there when I was a kid nice
dude there was a lot of interesting
stores uh and and yeah like going into a
place and just smelling it man we
whatever it's like I like we like to wax
uh nostalgic about [__] here on doozy
and um man there was a store actually at
the very end of my block when I was a
kid uh Cinnabon dude or not the block it
was way down the [__] Street up in
Ladner on Ladner trunk trunk Road
um Burger King dude hold on dude those
are restaurants brother
um restaurant dude now that's a store
that sells food brother what are you
doing that's my so there was a store way
way down the street it was called CKY
not to be mistaken with the band that
Bam Margera's brother was in yeah and uh
it was a great store it was just a
corner store but they always had they
had different video games in there over
the years I remember for a long time
they had kung fu yeah remember kung fu
I remember one time uh me and my good uh
buddy Matt we went in there and there
was like a Hostess chips or an Old Dutch
chips I hope it was all Dutch sure and I
tell you what I hope it was um lightly
salted but uh we went in there and got
these chips and there was a free
giveaway for another bag of chips in the
[__] this is like a fat kid dream you
could you you went in there and it was
like in some of the bags there was a
little thing that said free bag get
another bag of chips and you know what
if you just held it up to the sun you
could tell which ones had had the free
chips so there was one day where we just
like pilfered like 20 bags of chips yeah
every bag of chips in that store that
had free weed thing we get it we'd Take
It Outside eat them go inside play more
Kung Fu it was a real happening back in
the day with going to stores and that's
game slimers
I did a similar thing in another store
uh one of my other all-time favorite
stores well this was when I was in
junior high early part of high school
back in Carrollton Texas suburb of
Dallas it was called Kaboom comics and
stuff comic book store obviously Magic
the Gathering store that's where I was
really first introduced to Magic the
Gathering hahaha nerd early 90s this is
a guy who has a cardboard box full of
about a hundred pro wrestling figures
in the low 50s but okay so you could
back in the old days of Magic the
Gathering do the exact same thing with
magic the Gathering packs the packs were
kind of loose and the plastic was kind
of see-through so you could pop the
cards up in the back and you could see
what the rare card was in the pack
before you bought it that's awesome
every pack was pilfered like if you
didn't get there when a new box was open
you were [__] you're [__] you know
uh I love that story though there was a
store actually there was uh Charlie's
records and tapes which is when you know
you and your pals like we take the bus
downtown to Vancouver and we go to
Charlie's and there was a um some uh
there were these uh I saw one of them
there and then later when I moved to LA
there was a couple record stores in La
that had all of these CDs called
celebrities at their worst and I there
was like someone had like a set at
Charlie's but it was like underground
once I got to LA in my early 20s there
was uh celebrities at their worst you
remember these yes I do they were so
[__] dope because it was these off
weird recordings of like you know
um Casey case I'm getting pissed off
there was a famous one with William
Shatner where uh he's doing a voiceover
and he's like uh uh he's like do this do
that he's doing like a a Kirk and Spock
thing he's like Spock sabotage the
system
and the guy you hear the guy could you
remember trying to say sabotage and
Shatner's like you say sabotage I say
sabotage
don't tell me how to do it it sickens me
um literally what he said yeah uh remind
me to tell you my story about Shatner oh
you know what I'll tell you all about
that and dudes after doozy sure a fun
chat in her story because I did a series
with him for a year and uh we got to get
into this celebrities at the worst
stores a little bit I gotta say thinking
about Kaboom and going to those magic
the Gathering tournaments and just like
hanging out with your friends reading
comic books they had a Nintendo and Sega
set up we just [__] go in there for
hours and play like I don't know if it's
just youth that I don't do that anymore
like are there still stores that do that
kind of [__] that have cultures of like
people hanging out I'm sure I'm sure
there are but it's like you've seen our
team like I follow I know you do too but
like a couple of these like 80s 90s
Nostalgia Instagrams and um I saw this
cute meme the other day where it was
like this is how you used to find out
where your friends were and it's just a
pile of [__] BMX and mountain bikes
you know right in front of and that's
what we do you know in my town where we
grew up you just see you literally run
it oh yeah no they said they're you my
their mom would say oh they went over
they're trying to get a Hoops box there
was a local place too that had baseball
cards and [__] and then you go and if
there's a couple bikes parked out front
might be your friends you recognize
their bikes on that was a different time
dude yeah that was a different time I
missed stores kind of kind of
I don't know
thank you moving on oh my God Jesus
Christ
oh look at that this concludes the
historic 54th episode of doozy will and
Chad have achieved a score of 63
bringing your cumulative total to
5519. you only have
4481 more points to accrue before you
reach your first goal of ten thousand in
preparation for next week's episode will
and Chad you must each prepare vegan
muffin and bring them to the show next
week thank you for joining us this week
I will use the data I've collected to
make next week even better until then
call me doozy vegan muffin we gotta make
a vegan muffin we go from doozy
completely changing its [__] voice
and presentation and then this whole
thing with this mishigas that we've got
into at the top of the show to make a
vegan muffin yeah dude yeah dude that's
nice I had to make a vegan dish for each
other before remember that yeah that's
right and I didn't make it I went and
got a vegan Tiramisu and you enjoyed it
and I kind of feel like that's the that
that's the bottom line that you had a
good time and that's the bottom line
[Music]
[Applause]
dudes after duty here we are yes once
again yeah it's happening again because
it happens at the end of every single
show dudes you have to do these kind of
my favorite part of the show it's a bit
more of a chill mood you know it's a
little blue literally and figuratively
in here and uh we're just gonna get into
it it's time to hang with the pods take
a load off
chill out it's patreon do whatever the
[__] you want that's free will dude
the flagship weekly show of dude Z plus
this is my time for self-reflection and
Solitude so you can talk about anything
you want even football baby I won't be
here and I won't be listening but I will
be back to Crown this week's episode
champion this is dudes the after doozy
begin wow
his new voice is like he gets real
excited so it's nice it shoots us off
with purpose at the very beginning each
time all right well I like it uh
hey I got something I want to talk about
what's that
I saw uh last night the worst movie I've
ever seen really yes what was it
please
[Music]
do do
please